but he did try to fight me so I'm
walking into the kitchen he's walking
out and he leans his shoulder in the me
and I go uh did you just lean your
shoulder at me and he goes maybe you
should watch where you're going
I start laughs my god I'm sorry
are you starting to fight with me and he
goes yeah not that it's gonna be much of
a fight and I was like art man front
lawn right now let's go and he goes no
no not not now like three weeks I'm like
three who are you [ __ ] Rock he won
you need three weeks you gotta go turn
some tires over he goes I gotta go
videos online oh my god now listen
outwardly when he said three weeks I was
mocking him but on the inside when he
said three weeks I was like you because
I'm at an age where I pull muscles and I
bought muscles doing [ __ ] that I
shouldn't pull a muscle doing like not
too long ago I pulled a muscle in my
right shoulder wiping my ass I went back
too quick and didn't took my core it's
all core nowadays
when I went back to quick and all my
wife her when she walked by the door was
listen guys if I'm gonna stretch before
I [ __ ] you can kill me tonight you know
I don't like it if you walk into the
bathroom later and I'm like this and
you're like what are you doing man I'm
getting ready to poop like you can I
don't need to come out of the bathroom
you can kill me in there
now you're still by the way you couldn't
do what my dad did not this is this is
definitely something you could not get
away with now we have raised a different
generation of kids you guys know that
right
we have raised a generation of spoiled
entitled [ __ ] you understand that we
think laugh all you want but you know
whose fault it is
themselves guys it's our fault
and we've coddled them to the point or
that it's ridiculous do you know that in
a lot of states in our great country
they've outlawed dodgeball do you know
why because they say humiliates the
children rabble applause by the way
that's ironically why we played the
[ __ ] game to begin with right we may
cry today right right applause people
remember playing dodgeball we're on the
tables a place of dodgeball because we
share an experience right everybody in
here remember what that red rubber
tastes like on your lips right and your
eyes are watering your nose starts to
run you try to get off the court nine
other balls hit you and you're like
[Applause]
they'll never have that experience
really so I called my dad on the phone
and I know my son wants to fight me I
call him on the phone I'm like hey man
we all fought you right he goes yeah and
I said I seem to remember you being a
little more violent than you need it to
be and he said no yeah you remember
correctly and I said why why why why and
he goes with lism and he wants to win
right I said yeah he said you have to
win you have to win because if you don't
win the power changes at your house and
then you try tell him to take out the
trash tomorrow he's gonna slap you in
the face if you like you take the trash
out [ __ ] don't make me [ __ ] you up
again
and I was like oh my god he said this is
how and then he said something by the
way that I will never forget I go I have
to win he said Josh even if somebody
ends up calling the police you have to
win and I was like oh now listen I'm not
a violent dude my dad was more adept at
that and now I did have three older
brothers so I am really good at mental
torture so I was like that's kind of
where I'll lean on so I hang up the
phone and I turn around and my wife is
there and she looks right at me she goes
are you fighting Jacob and I said no no
I'm not gonna fight him it's gonna be
something weird do something the front
law it's not gonna be like a fight and
she said why why don't you just tell him
that you're the grown-up and he's the
kid and that's it he does what you say
and I'm like nah I said that's not gonna
work and she said why I said I'm not
sure if you were there but he basically
slapped me in the face with his dick in
the kitchen like there's only one
response she goes out I like it I said
I'm not saying it's the right response
I'm just saying it's the only one that I
know do you know and she said I don't
think this is a good idea and then I
maybe got a little too cocky and I said
I'll let you know when I have a bad idea
and she was like oh okay you're gonna
let me know and I said yeah and she goes
oh okay so I know I got to start
torturing my son right I called my
brother on the phone because I'm like
you guys tortured me endlessly what
should I do and he said what do you mean
all you talked about growing up was like
a wish I had a little brother so I could
do to him what you guys did to me he
goes now's your chance
nobody gets to go back and do that and I
was like you know you're you're right
this is quite an opportunity and he said
yeah man do you want me to send you over
the list oh my go
what list he goes or the list of things
that we had that we used to do to you
and I said why do you still have the
list and he was like you never know do
you
so he sends a list over right and I'm
looking at it and he said just remember
the most important thing is to start
small and go up from there so this all
started on a Sunday now listen he wants
three weeks I don't want to give him a
full three weeks I want to get this I
want to get him so mad my son that he
wants to fight at the end of the week I
need to get him so mad cuz that's the
only chance I have of beating him right
so my brother's like start slow okay so
Sunday night when my son is sleep and I
took all of his underwear out of his
drawer and I replaced it with panties
with the days of the week
[Applause]
so when he woke up the next morning I'm
a cooking breakfast and I hear from the
other room I hear whoa what is this hey
these are my underwear these are my and
I just yelled back they just put your
Mondays on sunshine and come on out for
some back and he was like I'm gonna
fight you so hard and I was like don't
say that don't say that don't say that
we hope you're not fighting me hard
[Music]
you